hey leute was genau von herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video ja leute
schafft natürlich stets gut bevor dieses
wieder losgeht ich kann euch sofort am
anfang sagen es wird echt ein richtig
heftiges video ich denke habe ich ein
titel auch schon gelesen bevor wir
anfangen muss ich noch einiges dazu
erklären
und ja ich würde sagen ich bin nicht
angelaufen fangen wir an also leute ich
muss euch mal kurz was zeigen
vielleicht kann sich aber noch der ein
oder andere dran erinnern und zwar ich
muss mal kurz gucken wann das war so
ungefähr vor einem jahr hab ich glaub
ich das letzte video dazu hochgeladen
und zwar waren das hier war so
experimente
das hier ist läuft das krasseste gewesen
das kann man auf mittlerweile gar nicht
mehr angucken 15 und 18 ist obwohl ich
eigentlich durchgehend drogen richtig
niedergemacht habe also eigentlich
sollte man daraus lernen genau hier
alkoholkonsum vor zuschauern oder das
allererste video dazu das war das hier
und zwar ja ich rauche experiment es war
einfach so eine idee von mir und ich hab
einfach so richtig lag eigentlich so
eine zigarette genommen um ihren mund
gesteckt ich meine da war ich noch nicht
so professionell wie jetzt hat das dann
einfach auf snapshot hochgeladen und die
reaktionen gefilmt und eigentlich
wirklich jeder sofort checken müssen
dass das fake ist ich mein guckt euch
dieses foto mal an wenn du das scharf
stellen würde
guckt euch das mal an ja dass ich jetzt
mal auf das video drauf das kam am 19 2
und 2016 also fast zwei jahre her ich
glaube das war einst mit meiner ersten
videos die schon so ziemlich polarisiert
haben und auch echt abgegangen sind also
der ein oder andere von euch sollte
dieses video auf jeden fall kennen ja
aber das ganze ist ja mittlerweile so um
die zwei jahre fast her
deswegen werden sich die meisten denke
ich nicht mehr daran erinnern und da ich
das wirklich so krass finde ich meinen
wenn denn youtuber rauf und das sagt das
ist ja mal echt so richtig war dass das
geht eigentlich nicht und ich zum
beispiel ich bin ja mittlerweile jetzt
auch nicht mehr so jung aber was so
rauchen angeht ich konnte das noch nie
ab wirklich ich finde es schmeckt
absolut scheiße und wieso sollte ich
jeden tag zum 506 euro für so einen
dreck skippen schachtel ausgeben ich
meine das sind im jahr fast 3000 euro ja
da wir auch wirklich sehr sehr viele von
meinen freunden und so weiter rauchen
was geht habe ich mir für heute so eine
art reloaded experiment überlegt und
dafür müssen jetzt ausmisten und
zigaretten kaufen ich habe das jetzt in
meinem leben zweimal gebrochen gekauft
weil ich die irgendwie mitbringen sollte
und heute ist das dritte mal
und heute benutze ich das wirklich für
mich selber und leute was dann auf jeden
fall noch hinzukommen damals als ich das
bei snapshot gepostet habe hatte ich
glaube ich weiß nicht dazu 4000 follower
mittlerweile sehen wir eine story halter
so 40.000 das heißt ja nochmal viel mehr
reaktionen darauf und ja also ich war
alles los war schon zu viel gelabert wir
sehen uns gleich so leute bei mir läuft
richtig habe jetzt was wir kaufen musste
nicht mal auswärts zeigen vor allem das
lustige ist ich glaube vor zwei jahren
als das video gemacht habe weiß ich
macht sein aber jetzt bin ich acht sind
das heißt es sogar egal ich brauche die
noch alle nichtraucher geben jetzt von
dort nach oben und ganz am ende
verbrenne ich die no
nein nein ich glaube brennen die ganze
schachtel safe so leicht ich bin jetzt
hier an seinem werk so mitten im
nirgendwo fast also hier ist zumindest
fast nichts und ich muss mich ein
bisschen beeilen weil das wird schon
gleich dunkel aber wir machen jetzt ein
cooles blick für meinen instagram sorry
also ich habe mich einmal diese
zigaretten gekauft und noch ein
feuerzeug
ich werde es gleich einmal kurz rauchen
oder vielleicht zwei mal und deshalb
auch foto festhalten dann posten auch
ein zaun
was passiert also ich würde das dann mal
so zwei schon drin lassen dass werden
locker so 20.000 menschen sehen und mal
gucken wie die reaktion darauf ist weil
dieses mal lasse ich das wirklich real
aussehen das letzte experiment so in
diese richtung ist jetzt auch schon so
fast ein jahr her deswegen denke ich
dass viele nicht mehr an sowas denken
und dann will ich mal gespannt auf kind
gibt's ja kein trick
welches klippen ob man das rauchen
aufgeben für ihre lieben weiterleben
also leute merkt euch das stimmt schon
so allein und wenn wir nicht mehr daran
zieht hier habe ich jetzt eine zigarette
kommt das ist so brutal eklig
so leute werden jetzt erstmal sofort und
fotos zu und zwar dass ihr das aber doch
ziemlich lasch also da kann man ja nicht
viel das könnte wieder ein krank sein
das passt jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
sofort in meine snapshot story und hier
habe ich jetzt noch die krasse und fotos
die bringe ich euch einfach mal kurz ein
aber vorerst jetzt weitergeht mit euren
ganzen rezensionen die er mir
hoffentlich hab meins neustadt auf
öffentlich müssen wir erst mal auf diese
tracks packung verbrennen also leute
wenn ihr auch tut mir den gefallen hört
bitte auf dank jo jo jo print das
brennen brennen bringt so leute wieder
sauber das kommt jetzt so ich habe jetzt
das foto gepostet und auch noch dass
hier das hat jetzt 2100 views nach
sieben minuten und diese leute haben
jetzt gerade schon geschrieben
wir sehen uns nur zwei stunden bis
gleich so etwas klappt und wir haben
jetzt gerade 19 uhr ich glaub ich habe
das so um viertel vor sechs gepostet das
heißt vor einer stunde ungefähr eine
stunde 15 minuten als es ist doch gar
nicht so lange her das problem ist halt
immer bei snap chat umso weiter man halt
oder umso mehr snaps man bekommt ich
kann auch mal zeit denn immer noch die
chats öffnung das ja blöd weil wir
wollen vielleicht auch mein video ist
oder so und deswegen fange ich jetzt
schon an werden gerade auch genau
halloween also die beiden apps haben
jetzt gerade 13.000 hughes und dann
haben wir einmal 376 screenshots und 251
screenshots schon viel also ich bleibe
euch die beiden fotos noch mal ein das
war einmal das hier und da war es halt
so ein bisschen so ja aber ihr wieder
fei und dann aber hier das zweite und
ich glaube daran die meisten eltern
meint das ernst
also es ist natürlich jetzt schwer zu
sagen wie viele leute mir daraufhin
geschrieben haben
aber ich würde mal so schätzen also das
geht eigentlich die ganze zeit so runter
keine ahnung 1000 1500 ja und ich sind
jetzt natürlich hier um das mit euch zu
öffnen vielleicht auch mal so ein zwei
wörter warum ich das video noch mal
gemacht haben also erstmal natürlich
viel mehr reichweite und im zweitens
einfach diese message rüberzubringen das
finde ich sehr
ich weil ich wirklich so komplett gegen
rauchen bin dass er klein schlingel wenn
ihr jetzt vielleicht aus 13 seite oder
so auf keinen fall damit anfangen ja
genau und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt auf
die rezension
ich glaube dass hatte damit nur wenig zu
tun so den ersten shuttle nicht geöffnet
habe ich dachte du wärst gegen rauchen
hör auf mit dem das ist scheiße du
solltest ein vorbild sein für andere
aber nein du nutzt dies aus und du
zeigst ihnen ein schlechtes vorbild
ich bin enttäuscht von dir du bist kein
besserer mensch wenn du deine zuschauer
wurde zwölf jahre sind sie sehen sich
als formel traurig dass diesmal also bei
deiner rechtschreibung müssen wir euch
nochmal sprechen aber jetzt finde ich
eine sehr gute einstellung wieso rauchst
du du bist schon oh folge klopp oder
nicht höher doch auf mit dem anstoß sein
leben kaputt
das ist das schöne sprache alex bitte
nicht auf das ist nicht gesund bitte von
du nicht auch noch an
bitte und wenn sie zehn minuten später
bitter aber man muss sagen man sich hier
dieses foto anschaut das sieht schon
echt cool aus oder ich meine so mit dem
filter also ich habe es bis jetzt auch
schon 2 mal gelesen auch schon wieder so
ein experiment das heißt der einmal
andere erinnert sich eventuell das wird
sicher ein gutes wie wir wissen dass du
nicht raus mach uns mal ins neue video
wir sind deine drei heftigsten fan girls
oder kennt sich wäre unverantwortlich
ausrufezeichen
die soll klar sein dass du für viele ein
vorbild bist und verantwortlich
ja das gehört ja das sehr sehr gut
zusammen gepasst das ist sehr schädlich
man kann dadurch krank werden deswegen
fand gar nicht erst an
ja bin jetzt raus was weiß nichts finde
ich cool findest du nicht glaubst du das
nicht geht soweit halloween feiern ja
schon eigentlich wollten wir schon noch
paar schachteln marlboro kaufen dann
geht es rund du sollst ein vorbild sein
fick dich ernsthaft vor allem so sie
schreibt vorbild wird dein ernst von dir
bin enttäuscht aber es wahrscheinlich
nur für ein video bester youtuber ich
bin das so unterhaltsame junge mann
höher auf vola sie nicht böse aber das
ist nicht cool erst sagen man braucht
nicht den videos aber läuft bei dir
theresa das ist doch nicht ernst gemeint
das ist halt jetzt zum schade diese
ganzen videos und so die halt vor einer
stunde schon geschickt wurden die kann
ich jetzt halt irgendwie nicht mehr
öffnen oder ich muss halt megalan
runterscrollen a hero mein gott eine
zigarette rauchen ja nee das ist nicht
gut im jahr darauf hören was gehört wenn
du das siehst brauchen nichts gute diese
zeit waren raus zu oder ist das wieder
ein prank wir damals mit pfiffen
erneut ist finde ich echt so gemein von
youtube ne ich hab da einfach so ein
video gemacht drogen genommen gegen wie
und das hat auch gepasst sind und ich
musste da so über meinen schatten
springen dass ich sowas wirklich wache
und dann hat dieses video so voll
polarisiert und es halt mega abgegangen
und dann doch das youtube com
das geht auf keinen fall das
stellenweise ab 18 aber wenn ihr 18 seid
schaut euch trotzdem sollte man muss
sagen die stimmen sind eigentlich wieder
eindeutig soll auch weil natürlich waren
auch so 34 dabei gemeint haben cool was
ich zu diesem thema noch abschließend
sagen möchte ich glaube sehr sehr viele
jetzt vor allem auf die noch etwas
jünger sind so 12 13 vielleicht 14
vielleicht auch schon 15 keine ahnung
ihr werdet euch wahrscheinlich jetzt
noch so denken hey rauchen damit fange
ich niemals an ja so war das in meinem
umfeld im frühjahr und irgendwann kann
man halt so die ersten partys wo dann
halt meine zigarette angeboten wurde
dann greift man da mal zu probiert das
mal und wirklich sehr viele machen es
öfter irgendwann zu abhängig und dann
den rest ihres lebens und eigentlich nur
weil man das irgendwann als jugendlicher
mal ausprobiert hat und ja ist dann halt
irgendwie nicht falsche richtung
gelaufen
deswegen gab es wieder einmal ich hoffe
natürlich jetzt hat euch gefallen an
unterhalten lassen nach oben da bin ich
nichtraucher sei das wird mein erstes
video von mir was ich selber live und
jacksons tod auf jeden fall ab und
instagram und wir sehen uns dann morgen
oder übermorgen wieder haut rein